hey it's Spencer Ackerman with danger
room on the showroom floor of the
Association the US Army's 2011
conference checking out an upgrade to
one of the Army's favorite drones the
shadow UAV that thing won't kill you it
certainly will spy on you and with some
of the upgrades that AI and texture on
have made to it will spy on you a lot
better for a lot longer it's got a new
60 horsepower engine under the hood
which keeps it in the air for a lot
longer and inside that great button
mayor is essentially a whole other
payload day so you can put a lot more
spy gear in there or you can load it up
with a lot more fuel to make sure it
stays on the arrow a lot longer outside
it at pretty much the same drum the
Army's been flying in Iraq and
Afghanistan since 2001 about the same
size a little bit heavier but really the
upgrades through the engine and to that
new payload bay